[Music]
lot about underly
there not any there's like one pure
place
like at least video that
okay very U very quick reminder though
you probably don't need it given how
often I've said this but your first quiz
is a week from I'm sorry is on Monday
first 30 minutes of class 1:30 to2 so
please don't be late there will be class
after the quest so you finish up you're
welcome to go out get a cup of coffee
finish early but come back at 2:00
because we will pick
up um if you've signed up at the Moses
Center and I noticed that a couple of
you have for you know for you know for
special accommodations make sure you let
them know that you're taking the exam
there that's your only way you can
actually physically take the exam so in
case
that so today we're going to continue
our discussion of cash flows and we're
going to probably towards the end of
today talk about free cash flow to
equity now I kind of concocted this term
in the 199 90s when I was writing one of
my books because there's nothing
equivalent out there it sounds fancy but
it's a cash flow left over after every
conceivable need has been met capex
working capital and your free cash FL
Equity can sometimes be negative
especially if you're valuing a young
company explain why why why does it
happen why do young company Jessica why
would young companies have negative free
cash flows to
equity let's dig deeper what what is
free cash equities cash left off over
after every need right first what do
young companies make in terms of profits
usually money losing so you start with a
negative number do they have to reinvest
a
lot yeah because they want to grow right
you take a negative number you reinvest
a lot your free cashlo Equity is going
to be negative it's a feature not about
so when you value young companies even
the most promising young companies your
free cash flows Equity are going to
start off negative would you like them
to get less negative over time or more
negative hopefully you hope that they
move in right direction but even in a
healthy young company you can have four
five six years of negative free Cas prod
have very simple in two to question and
Jessica if you want to pass this off
you're welcome tip but in a discounted
cash flow valuation we just take those
cash flows we discount them and then we
keep moving what are we implicitly
assuming that this company is going to
be able to do next year when you say
it's negative free cash or minus billion
what are we implicitly assuming in our
valuation it's going to be able to
do got to come up with the money
somewhere right Julian help her out so
it's got to come up with the money
somewhere but but it's got to cover that
negative cash flow to keep going where
do Young companies usually raise money
you got to go to venture capitalist you
got to go to family you tap out
everybody and hopefully you raise enough
money so even the highest po potential
companies need to raise Capital to keep
going through that period and in
discounted cash flow valuation we act
like that's not a big
deal but could it be a big
deal could you not I mean is it possible
that even though you're coming in on
track in terms of your negative free
cash Equity that you can't cover that
money
BR it's not very likely otherwise
startups will crash into burn what might
cause it to happen is something causes
the money to dry out you know 2001
startups were dying like 50 a week why
because after the dot crash venture
capital is pull back saying no 2022 more
recently VC's pull back saying no we're
not providing Capital that is a very
real possibility and when you do
discounted cash flow valuation if you
ignore that possibility you're going to
overvalue Young companies you see why
because you're always assuming that they
make it through to heal so we're going
to talk more about that when we talk
about valueing young companies how do
you factor in that failure risk and it's
going to be greater in markets outside
the US because you don't have as much
access to venture capital outside what
do you do when that
happens who's doing the money losing
company in this class at least one in
five right has you know somewhere around
there dixa what's the company what's the
company you're doing the money losing
company Mona why is Monna losing money
inv in R&D and no no no wait wait wait
investing is a negative cash flow
argument right losing money is so we're
talking about losing money on the
earnings but why is it why is why do you
have negative Abit
Abit the expenses are very high and
what's the biggest single expense that's
very
high r& right and accountant expensive
so Mona's loss is kind of cosmetic right
because its biggest capex is shown as
OPC so it's not quite fair to say that
they're losing money but they so if
you're valuing the company and let's say
you're projecting it out and you think
the MRNA technology is going to catch on
and Other Drugs it's going to show up as
higher revenues and but the earnings are
not going to turn positive next year or
two years out it's going to take a what
six seven years if you and if the rest
of the stuff plays out
anybody else doing a money losing
company come on all the hands went down
very quickly okay wa who are you
doing oh that's right you mentioned this
right it might be so difficult for
people to even relate to right now but
why is it losing money um just they
didn't earn enough to cover the cost
that's a me that's true for any company
losing money right the revenue is less
than the than the operating expenses so
that tells you nothing but what is it
about the company that's making them
lose
money think they to spend a lot in
acquiring new customers so they're young
company they're growing so you know
there in a sense like Mna they have to
grow themselves out of the problem is
anybody picked a money losing company
that's more
mature uh Boeing and Boeing we you know
this is a you could do a case study an
entire MBA program around Boeing and
what's wrong with it clearly it's not a
young Growth Company right it's not
going to scale up to
success the problems are
structural they're
legal because who knows what lawsuits
are coming and also there's an issue of
credibility when you
sell these tube plastic tubes that 300
people get on and trust you to take you
up in the air and bring you back down if
you're not credible if people feel that
you can't be trusted that is
catastrophic
737 Max thing did such serious damage
that they're still trying to dig out of
it right so Bing is losing money for a
very different reason than m is losing
money does it matter why a company loses
money I mean it could lose money because
of a one-ear loss there are some
companies who lose money because they
had a strike last year going before it
737 Max proms every 10 year would have a
one year where they lost money because
they' have a three Monon stri that's how
they negotiated with their the Unions
would walk off it was like clockwork 3
months later they'd settle but they'd
have to take a billion billion and a
half2 billion right off that year it
could be because um you had some
temporary problem last year but it's now
gone away right it could also be that
you know that the that that there are
lots of things happening fundamentally
but lots of people in the value money
losing companies take the shortcut what
they do is they take the loss promise
the minus and they replace with a plus
by taking the average earnings over the
last five years that's not going to work
for a young company because the average
earnings over the last five years will
also be negative it might work for mod
2020 gave them a little but it's really
not a meaningful number do you see
already when you take the average
earnings Over The Last 5 Years often
given as a recipe you're making a lot of
implicit assumptions you're assuming
that the loss has gone away that's
unusual it's a one-time loss that the
problems are not structural right struct
not coming back so if you decide to
normalize earnings by replacing negative
earnings with positive earnings make
sure that all these conditions are met I
tell the kinds of companies could
probably get away with commodity company
where you have a cycle right there you
saying the cycle is still there I'm just
going to take the average earnings over
the last five years so we're going to
talk about looking at why are companies
losing money and then asking the
question what do we do about it because
there's no one rest
that's going to work for every company
so let's go back to where we were in the
notes you have no idea where we were but
I remember where we were so I'll get you
there and talk about R&D remember the
the the task I gave you when you left
the class does anybody remember what I
asked you to think
about D I'm going to come back to you
because you have a company where this is
obviously an issue that's altering all
your numbers R&D is being expensed right
and if you think about everything your
accounting class taught you about capex
capex being an expense that creates
benefits over many years this makes no
sense so why do you think accountants do
something that makes no sense and they
keep doing
it think like an accountant but not snap
out of it very quickly you know think
for a brief moment like an accountant
because you get the answer
that would be too
sensible now the the answer it was given
us tax benefits that's a good reason now
that I would expense right though that's
starting to change you know the 2022 tax
law change you can no longer completely
expense r&t you got advertise it over 5
years I found out about it the hard way
somebody not valued a company to expense
or no no you can't do that
anymore about 12 years ago I was asked
to give the keynote address to the aicpa
conference you know the aicpa conference
is a thousand CPAs from around the
country gathered together usually in Las
Vegas kind of in congruous if you think
about it in because Las Vegas is the
biggest
ballrooms so they asked me to come and
give the keynote and I said are you sure
you got the right guy they said no no
come on any so I showed up and this's
this big Ballroom filled with a th
accountants kind of close to my vision
of hell as I can get and I'm trapped
with a thousand accountants in a room
and then I gave a talk that made sure I
would never get invited back again the
title of my session was 10 things
accountants do that I don't quite
get one of them was of course Lees
because pre
2019 and now was R&D said what the heck
are you guys doing you told me that any
expense that creates benefits over many
years is a capital expense and then here
you're taking R&D which is the ultimate
capex and you're expensing it so what do
you think the most commonly given reason
for expensing was M because the future
benefit is not guaranteed exactly you're
thinking like an accountant about
certainty and uncertainty they said it's
two the benefits are too uncertain we're
going to expense it I said okay what if
I built a factory in kazakistan
would you let me expense it Borat could
come and burn it down
tomorrow there are parts of the world
where you you can build a a big assembly
plan you have no idea what uncertainty
is not a dividing line let me use on any
other capex how come you selectively use
it for
R&D it's a terrible reason for expensing
something so you know the fallback
reason was we're just being
conservative it's a big deal with
accountants I'm just being conservative
in what sense when you expense R&D you
lower earnings right so we're reporting
less earnings that's conservative
but what else are you doing when you
expense something what what's happening
in your balance sheet what are you
showing in your balance sheet nothing
your biggest assets are off the books if
you're a technology company or
pharmaceutical you're saying so what
we're going to talk a lot about how
growth and value are driven by what do
you think the return in equity or return
on capital is for a company how well
they're investing and how do we compute
those numbers we take the earnings and
we divide by Book value one place in
finance we rest on Book value the the
book value comes from the balance sheet
you see what's going to happen in
companies where your biggest
capex is treated as an operating expense
there'll be nothing on the balance sheet
we don't believe me take any technology
comp company computer return Equity
you're going to get astronomically High
numbers even for very average software
companies you get 100% return
Equity that's not
conservative so uncertainty is not a
good reason being conservative then
there is no good reason let me save you
the trouble if you're trying to think of
a third good reason there are no good
reasons so why haven't they done
something about it because it takes them
a really long time to act and this is a
legacy problem because this isn't just
R&D it's a whole host of other expenses
You could argue that in most companies
capex is no longer building a factory
filling it up with equipment and making
stuff right take a look at the top 20
companies in the
US I'll challenge you to find me one
Manufacturing Company in the mix you're
saying what about Nvidia Nvidia doesn't
make its own chips it designs its chips
tsmc makes
them accounting was designed for the
oldtime manufacturing company it might
have worked in 1950 and 1960 and maybe
into the 70s it's a stretch to the Limit
and they have no idea what to do I'll be
quite honest it's not an easy fix
because you got to rewrite Accounting in
a sense and that means 100 Years of CPA
are down the drain right because
everything you've been taught in
accounting has to be retaught so we're
not going to wait for accountants to do
the right thing we're going to do it
ourselves and it's not difficult to do
there a lot of moving pieces let me take
you through the process how I would
capitalize
already first step is I'm going to ask
you a question it's not an easy question
to answer but it's a question you have
to deal with anyway if you're a company
doing R&D here's the question on average
how long how long does it take between
the time you do R&D and a commercial
product emerges on average you see why I
through the on average right I
understand some R&D will not pay off
some R&D will pay off in two years some
in five some in seven give me an average
so let's say you're looking at a
software company on average how long
should it usually
take probably year two years 3 years
maybe pharmaceutical
company if you're lucky 10 years right
you got to come up with a product it's
got to go through three stages now once
in a while you might be helped out by a
pandemic there is no way Mna would have
been approved if Co hadn't come along
right it was no but it
takes I'm going to pick a company in the
middle the application software much
more involved let's say five
years here's the thing I'm going to do
I'm going to go back and collect your
r&t expenses each year for the last 5
years he's saying why are you looking
backwards because if I decide to
capitalize
R&D I have to act like I've been doing
this all the way along because I've got
to make everything updated not just my
income state so I'm going to collect R&D
expenses for The Last 5 Years now the
last step if R&D takes 5 years to pay
off what's a logical way to deal with it
in my income
statement write off 1/5 each year right
don't do any speci some of the digits no
no special stuff just write off
150 and I'm going to keep track of two
numbers how much I'm writing off this
year each and how much is still left off
so let me try this for with sap there
sap is a German software company
competes very much with Oracle and the
other business services
software fiveyear life I got the r
expense for the current year the current
year just ended so when we talk about
current year and finance it's always the
year just ended and then I go last year
two years ago three years ago so the
Last 5 Years let's say 5 years ago they
had 745 million 745 million EUR in R&D
if I'd been capitalizing what should I
have been doing writing off 1if every
year I'm writing off the last 1th this
year and it's off the
books four years ago 969 million I'm
writing off5 there's still 1th left over
3 years ago I'm writing off 1/5th
there's two fifths left over so
basically I'm keeping track of how much
I'm writing off and what's left over if
you add up the last column you come up
93 million Eur
if you're wondering what that is that
would have shown up in my income
statement is amortization of past R&D
right the R&D invested if you add up the
second to last column I come up with 2.9
billion you're saying what the heck is
that that's not going to show up on my
balance sheet as an asset you can call
it a research asset or capital
investment R&D but because it's showing
up on the balance sheet something has to
change on the other side right there
only two items debt or Equity at the
case of leases it was debt that went up
in the case of R&D it's Equity that's
going to go up because comes out of
after tax earnings so my book Equity
will increase by 2.9 billion and finally
when I look at my operating income I now
will add back this year's R&D expense
saying I should never have subtracted
out it's a capital expense and I'm going
to subtract our depreciation so my
operating income is going to increase by
117 million because I'll be now
subtracting out a smaller
number than I did before so let's look
at the the the after effects the debris
that comes out of capitalizing r&y I
have higher earnings and for most
technology and PHA companies that's
probably going to be true in Monna if I
capitalize R&D they might very well
become a money-making company your loss
might very quickly go away because if
80% of your expenses are R&D and I
capitalize it you were actually making
money on the stuff you were selling was
just hidden under this Ary I have more
earnings my book Equity will be higher
right because I'm now brought the asset
my return and Equity can get both ways
depending on which effect dominates it
changes my entire perspective on the
company so I'm going to take you through
sap and do what I did with The Gap look
at each slice and look at what the
effect is because my ultimate end game
is value I don't care about all these
middle steps right first step I start
with the operating income Sap's
operating income is $1,285 million
before I capitalize R&D after I
capitalize it it's higher because I'm
now adding back the R&D expense and
subtracting how the amotization I have
higher
earnings on the balance sheet my book
value is 3,768 million with conventional
accounting that number is now going to
be 6782 million I'm adding on the R&D
asset much bigger book Equity I far more
in assets when I do my capex with
traditional capex it looks like the
company's reinvesting nothing in fact if
you take modna look at the statement of
cash flows look at capex think this
company's reinvesting nothing for the
future that's extremely
unfair so I'm going to bring in the
effect of R&D by you know looking at the
R&D and the am it's like net capex R&D
minus amortization my reinvestment goes
from 2 million to19
million but here's something that's
going to puzzle you and I ask you why
are we do wasting our time in this in
the first place when I compute the free
cash flow to the
firm for sap it remains exactly the same
you see why though right whether I spend
money on R&D whether I call it capex I'm
spending the money anyway all it's doing
is changing the ingredients that go into
my free cash of the firm I far more in
earnings and Far More in capex you're
saying but ultimately don't I just care
about free cash of the firm you do but
in forecasting the future you need to
know how much of that money went into
reinvestment and how much came from
actual earning so madna if I just leave
it as is there are money losing company
that's reinvesting close to nothing
that's a disaster waiting to happen if
that is in fact the truth thank God it
isn't because they have lot more in
capex a reinvest it's better to be a
money losing company if you have a lot
of reinvestment that goes with it
because there's at least that Nirvana of
growth kind of hanging out that that'll
allow me to kind of grow out of it we
capitalize R&D because it gives us a
much better perspective when what the
company's actually doing and we need
that to estimate growth as a final piece
I estimated the return on Capital
remember I said there's a one place in
finance we use book values that's a book
value of equity plus the book value of
debt the return on Capital would have
been based on the book value their
original earnings in this case when I
capitalize R&D their return on Capital
decreases by about 5% it's still a very
good number but it doesn't look as good
as it looked when I use the conventional
account numbers so be clear on why we're
capitalizing r&t it's not to get a
better estimate of the free cash of the
firm it's not to somehow change the
numbers in the company to get a better
perspective on what the company is doing
or not doing I'll tell you if you don't
do this how farmer companies and tech
companies can fool you as an investor if
all you get focused on is the bottom
line what can I do as a tech or a farmer
company to make it look like I'm doing
much better in when in fact I'm cutting
my heart out as as a company what's the
easiest way to increase earnings know
Monna if it wants to make its earnings
become positive next year all they need
to do is make their R&D zero right I'm
going to reward them say look the
earnings went up and if your R&D is zero
where is your future growth going to
come from we're almost begging with
technology companies to have games and
earnings in V is going to come out with
the earnings today you know for the last
14 quarters in various beaten and an
expectations when you beat expectations
14 quarters in a row then they're not
expectations anymore clearly the company
can play discretionary games they can
see what your expectations are and they
have enough given this process that they
can adjust how much they spent on R&D
and other Capital expenditures look we
beat earnings by 7
cents you know who's not fooled
September last September inv videoid
beat expectations on every Dimension and
it's talk price down
8% analysts might be fooled but Market
say hey we're not fooled we can see how
you increased earnings it doesn't make
sense in terms of increasing your value
as a company so what accountants are
doing right now with R&D is lowering
earnings at companies further than they
should or you know technology and farmer
companies their book Capital doesn't
measure what it's supposed to do and
what we're trying to do is compensate
yes Julie
you know what if markets are not fooled
I familyless are fooled who cares right
they deserve to be fooled in many ways I
have zero sympathy for that markets I
mean this is why when people think
markets follow analysts all you need to
do is look at what markets do and you
very quickly see it's analy following
markets rather than the other way around
so if they want to play this stupid game
among themselves let them play it
doesn't really matter to me because as
an investor in Nvidia what I care about
is what the stock price does
so if markets are not being fooled then
I can live with it if markets are being
fooled then we have the potential for
real disasters
here that's a good question now you
could argue that Nvidia is playing more
games now than there were for the
problem is that expectations keep
getting raised and because they keep
getting raised they have to play games
now to catch up to those expectations
maybe what they need to do is start
bringing expectations down I'd love to
see Jensen W get and say you guys are
getting a little overheated about this
AI thing you know we don't think there's
going to be6 billion dollar of6 trillion
dollars of AI products and services out
there but I don't think he can do that
because meta and Microsoft are going to
say what the heck did we spend 80
billion on your chips for in the first
place so but I think expectations have
gotten way out of
control now just as with leases where we
talked about other expenses like relases
with R&D that are are items like R&D
that have the same as treatment right
let me give you a few categories oil
companies what's an item analogous to
R&D you seen oil companies which you
think should be capex but street is an
operating
expense exploration
cost it's expens your Uber what the
biggest
capex acquiring customers is capex so
this is not just pharmaceutical
companies and technology companies I
would argue that this is your problem in
many companies 80% of companies you
value thinking about what expenses are
really your capex and moving them to the
right column is going to give you a much
much more sensible perspective and
you're going to use exactly the same
framework let's move to the next aspect
of Earth let's suppose you have a
company it's reporting a loss of a half
a billion but it's coming entirely from
a one-time charge of a billion
you're valuing this company it's got a
loss right but it's coming entirely from
what's the easiest way to get rid of the
loss here it's truly a onetime loss take
it out of the process and your operating
income will then be a half a billion
right that's what we often do with
extraordinary items and companies know
we do it so you know what they've
started doing right they've started
gaming the system one of the ways you
gain the system is you bundle together
operating expenses at every five or 10
years years you take a one-time
charge what's a onetime charge that
shows up every 5 years it's definitely
not a onetime charge it's a one fif of a
Time charge each year that you're
bundling so let's suppose every five
years you see this company one time
charge of a
bell how would your answer be
different from the in the first scenario
you just basically added the entire
amount back but if every 5 years you get
a onetime charge of a
billion What would your adjusted
operating income look
like go ahead France try then it's
obviously not a one time charge and I
would consider but in this case if you
think about 1 billion every five years
means it's really a $200 million charge
they've charged a billion so you're
going to add back 800 million not the
entire billion your normalized income
you see what how got the 800 million
basically it's you know the actual
charge be so the profit I would CE you
making is 300 million minus 500 now do
you see the advantage of having access
to a service like Capital like you
because you can look at the entire
history of the company you can see items
every year and if you see every fourth
or fifth year this big lump sum it's
time to get a little suspicious about
whether it's truly a one-time
chge which brings me to what I think is
potentially the most thorny isue
valuation or raw data comes from
accounting
statements now if accountant is being
inconsistent you can fix it if
accountants make judgments you don't
agree with you can change it but if
accountants are committing fraud you are
completely and totally
screwed so how do you know whe When
account I mean after the fact obviously
you find out but what are some of the
clues you might look
at for accounting
fraud so actually of accounting called
forensic accounting right it developed
starting in the 1990s with the enw The
Tao forensic accountants are more boring
than actuaries I mean there are really
people who are you know would call them
soulless but they're like you know very
methodical so what they do is they go
through income statements and balance
sheets and financial statement looking
for Clues on what companies that because
the clues are going to show up somewhere
I'll give you one of the things I look
for when you look at an income statement
you get the acral income of a company
okay if you go to the statement of cash
flows in that first section where you
take net income you add back
depreciation you subtract our change in
working capital you come up with a
measure that's called Cash income so
basically have a cruel income and cash
income and for most companies the cruel
income and cash income go back and forth
some years the cruel income is higher
some years the cash income is higher but
if year after year after year the the
the acual income runs ahead of the cash
income something is going on that you
need to find out some inventory is being
registered sales it's never being sold
so that's one of the clues none of these
is definitive not no so you're not going
to say fraud just based on that you have
changes in the effective tax rate it
goes from 28% to minus 11% to plus 35%
to minus 50% companies obviously
maintaining two sets of books a
reporting book and tax books and they're
different yeah you're looking for sgna
sgna is this lump God only knows what
goes into it and as a person of revenues
it goes from 53% to 85% to 65% something
is being thrown in there that shouldn't
be so what you looking for is a
collection of Clues and if those Clues
come together and you don't trust the
accounting then you say what do I do
pick a different company right so
there's really not a whole lot you can
do you can report it to the authorities
and hope they do something about it and
that's basically what outfits like
Hindenburg do is they do their version
of forensic accounting and once they
find something they're not quiet about
it they release this 150 page report and
all the accounting they with the I with
Ian Enterprise which is kind of you know
a turnaround for Carl Ian who does it on
other companies and being done to him
that's that becomes the basis for short
selling because if that is in fact
something that that is happening under
the surface and you can bring it to the
surface then all kinds of bad things
happen to the company and its stock
price so I'll send you a couple of links
on Forensic accounting if you're
interested let's close off the earnings
discussion by going back to the money
losing
company when I look at a money losing
company the first question I ask is why
right and I could go with wit's answer
which is the expenses are greater than
the revenues that's why but that gets me
not very far right so here are the four
reasons you can have a money losing
company so as I go through these reasons
think of it whether it applies to you
the first is it can be a one time or an
extraordinary charge if we take Boeing
obviously that's not it they've had
extraordinary charge but it seems to be
happening every year there something is
a pattern it could be a macro Factor if
you have a cyclical or a commodity
company and the commodity price had
collapsed or the economy is in
recession then obviously you're going to
be losing money in those first two
scenarios you can fix a problem pretty
quickly right basically you can take
next year income and say I'm going to
take out the onetime charge the economy
is going to come back so those are the
Easy Money losing companies to deal with
right but then you have two com two
groups of companies where the problem is
much
deeper which company uh and dixes
Company both are young companies the
problem is not going to go away there
you got to pick a Target
margin little easier for dict because
he's going to be going into a
pharmaceutical business we have a sense
of what the margins look like you could
say I think think mni eventually is
going to converge on those margins and
you have tell me at what scale what are
the products going to
be but what what's your target here what
do you think uh Health do you have any
healthy companies out there you got to
find something to Target right and that
you might have to go back to Bas is it a
service business a platform business
what are the unity
economics it's a much tougher task
because you have to pick a Target margin
and then you got to nurse your company
to the Target margin
hoping and praying you make it to it
right that's a failure risk coming
in people often get intimidated but I
think it's actually interesting more fun
to work with these companies it makes
you think about all the basics of
businesses scaling up effects
yeah if you are a young Growth Company
what do you have have to do to make up
for it how do discount retailers live
with really low
margins Costco margins are 4% great
company what do they do to make up for
the low
margins no that is only part the
Walmart's low margins it's a six you
know and you think about it it's one of
the more valuable companies in the
country
France you have to sell a lot right I
mean remember there's nothing wrong with
low margins so if you say low margins
and low sales then you're kind of
looking at a deadly scenario right but
if you're low margins and you can sell a
lot you're okay okay you can still get
to a pretty reasonable return on Capital
and value so the low margins by
themselves won't Doom you but if the
revenues you get those low margins turn
out to be low it's going to be tough to
get your negative cash flows back
right so we've got the operating income
it took us a while to get there we
cleaned it up we normalized it we
updated it now we get to that 1 minus t
next to the number right now now when we
did cost of debt we dealt with this
issue of a tax rate there what was the
rule we adopted what's a tax rate you
always used to get an after tax cost of
De sorry what marginal don't say you
said because I want you to be
comfortable with why it's a margin tax
because you are going to run into people
where this because this is one of the
more common problems is people use
effective tax so tell me why we use the
marginal tax it's a little unfair now
because I told you know I kind of sent
that message but what is it about
interest expenses that lead you to use
the marginal tax rate because we need to
yeah to focus on the last dollar so the
why do we focus on the last
dollar the but why do we focus on the
last dollar how do interest expenses how
many of you going to file your own taxes
this year I haven't even started but
somewhere along the way in the next six
weeks we have to right think about
making a million dollar in income if I'm
insulting you at an extra zero right 10
million 100 million whatever makes you
happy right million dollars in income
and you have $100,000 in interest
expenses think of what happens right you
take the million you subtract out the
100 you report taxable income of 900,000
you save taxes on the last 100,000
interest saves taxes for you at the
margin so your average tax rate your
effective tax rate is kind of irrelevant
Apple's effective tax rate is 12% I can
almost guarantee you that on those h100
billion in debt and the interest
expenses they're getting close to 25%
which is the Us corporate tax rate you
find your highest tax income you set it
gain so that's why we use the marginal
tax rate when we do after tax cost a Deb
we're now encountering a second place
where we need a tax rate now we're
applying a tax rate not to interest
expenses but to all of our operating
income keyword is all of the operating
income so here are the choices you have
you could use the effective tax rate
which is the tax rate you find in in the
income statement taxable income taxes
divided by taxable income you could use
a tax rate you compute by taking taxes
paid and dividing by operating income
which is going to be lower than the
effective tax rate because the operating
income is further up you could use the
marginal tax rate for the country in
which you're
Incorporated you could use a weighted
average marginal tax rate if you're in
25 different
countries maybe it's none of the above
in which case I'm going to put you on
the spot so you got to give me a number
right or maybe this would be great if it
were true any of the above as long as
you stay
consistent if that were the case you
know what we uses tax rates and
valuations all the time what's the
easiest tax rate to work with in
valuation zero if taxes didn't matter
and all you had to do is be consistent
we wouldn't even bring taxes in clearly
it matters so that choice is off the
table so really the choice is between an
effective tax rate and a marginal tax
we go back and and revisit something I
told you at the start of that that tax
rate discussion which one did I say is
usually higher for most companies
effective or marginal marginal the
marginal tax rate in the US is roughly
25% the effective tax rate in 2024 was
about 18% the company app 12% 133% 14%
there are a few companies with effective
tax is high but for most companies
effective tax rates are lower than
marinal tax rate so the question is so
let's say you take cap you got a 12%
effective tax rate a 25% marginal tax
rate let's play it out I could use the
effective tax rate saying that's
actually what I'm paying and I will
continue to do it every year Forever on
my on my
earnings and value the company I could
use the marginal tax rate and value the
company the marginal tax rate first if I
use the effective tax rate all the way
through I'm going to get a higher value
for the company everybody great because
I'll have lower taxes more after tax
operating income but what am I
implicitly assuming that I'll be able to
do when I use the effective tax rate
every year
forever what causes effective tax rates
Bel low the marginal tax rates goes
through some of the reasons
Michael no remember it's on taxable
income so the so what we use to get
effective tax rate is taxes paid divide
by taxable income so all of the
deductions are already in there already
when you get to the taxable income right
so it can be things depreciation and
other expenses I've already netted them
outet brackets for individuals it's tax
brackets right companies that very
quickly goes away right because you hit
the highest tax bracket like three
million so for compan like apple that
was so long ago you don't even remember
two reasons one is that you have a lot
of income in foreign countries remember
the one of the things the 2017 tax law
also changed in addition to the tax rate
is it you know it gave the same tax or
it applies through much of the world for
us companies which is if you make income
in another country with a 15% tax rate
you have to pay the 15% but you're done
pre 2017 the US had one of the most
perverse tax codes on the face of the
Earth there are 40% marginal tax rate
and then they also said if you make
income in another country and you make a
15% tax rate you have to pay the extra
25% when you bring the money back to the
US I don't know who writes tax laws or
what they think will happen tell me as a
company if I write it that way and
you're a multinational with a lot of
income in other countries what are you
going to do you're never going to bring
it back in 2017 there were $2 trillion
in
trapped taxes you saying trapped by who
trapped by the US government because
those companies said I'm not bringing
the money back Apple alone had $150
billion in trap cash
2017 that was one of the healthier
things that came out of it is that game
is gone so one reason your tax rate
could be low effective is because you
have a lot of foreign income that could
continue for the long term but there's
another reason effective tax rate can be
lower than the marginal tax and that
is you have a lot of tax lawyers around
looking for ways that you defer taxes
right if that's a reason be very careful
about leaving the tax rate at 12%
because if you do what are you about
deferred
taxes now not only can you defer taxes
next year two years or you can defer
taxes
forever never pad sell in a federal
penitentiary waiting for you if you
think that's going to happen right it's
not going to happen because you are
again assuming something that cannot be
done so if you're in the second group
which is the more common
group you can start with the effective
tax rate because right now you found a
way to say taxes I'm not going to take
it away from you but over time remember
you have a time Horizon you know you
start now and you start to move towards
a terminal value when things start when
when growth starts to lower is when your
effective and marginal tax rates start
to converge so I'm going to let you use
a 12% tax rate for Apple next year two
years out three years out four years out
five years out but then I'm say wait
know but if you think this tax rate is
going to go to 25% I'm going to start to
move that tax rate from 12 to 25% as I
move to the terminal the fcff simple
Ginsu spreadsheet the default is I ask
you for an effective tax in marginal tax
rate the default is I use the effective
tax rate for the next 5 years and then I
start moving it toward a marginal tax
rate but then I let you override the
default I said look you know if you want
me to leave it at 12% I will leave it at
12% maybe of a good reason but think
about it that's what's driving this
choice of effective versus marginal tax
rates any questions on on the tax rate
question so bottom line I think the most
sensible thing to do is start with the
effective tax rate and move towards the
margin one of the good things about
marginal tax rates is global marginal
tax rates are converging around
25% that didn't used to be the case
there was a point in time we had 40% tax
rates and 5% tax rates you have outliers
still like irel
12% I think the highest corporate tax
right now might be Japan like 32 33% but
it's the us used to be up there 40% it
was big as the biggest economy it had in
a disproportionate role in kind of
skewing what companies did as a
consequence one final point if you have
a money losing company dixa has a money
losing company Wht has a money losing
company boing as a money losing company
what are you allowed to do with your
losses
when you can carry them forward it's
called an nool and if you look at know
mod financial statement somewhere in the
footnotes they'll tell you how much that
nool is and if you've been a money
losing company for a long time that nool
can be billions of dollars why do they
keep track of
it ta if you start to make money you're
allowed to
offset the the taxes you're paid by the
fact that you so let's take a very
simple example with nice round numbers
you don't need to calculate let's say
you have a company with a billion
dollars in no and it's now expect to
start making money for the next 3 years
and let's keep the profits 500 million
every year for the next 3
years given that you have a billion
dollar nool what will your taxes be in
your
one zero but remember your n is now down
to 500 million keep track of it taxes in
your two zero again n is now gone now do
you see why it's critical that you keep
track of the N otherwise you'll be
claiming tax benefits well after the N
is gone you know if you look at again my
FC
the simple grins is spr it looks at the
N you come in I ask you for the N which
you have to supply as an input but every
year that you lose money I add to the
nool and then when you start making
money I use it to save your taxes
because that's the way the world works
it's best I mean people sometimes keep
NS out of the valuation and bring it in
the last step I don't like that because
your effective nool is primarily through
save taxes in future years and this
allows you to capture
that it used at one point in time you
couldn't carry your NS for more than 7
years forward they've removed that cap
for a very simple reason if you're
carrying your n for that long they
discovered you're not around anywhere
it's kind of a pointless Gap to have so
now you just keep carrying an still you
run out of
them
capex again capex Vision you have
Factory equipment yes
just you don't have to right because you
put a loss just the loss goes in it's a
mathematical computation so if I know
your income statements for the last
three years and I can see how much you
lost each year your nool is just the sum
of those losses so it comes it so the
income statement is what drives the no
it's not a number that you have to prove
separately it's just the summation of
your losses over your
life for individuals we get tax a lot
more unfairly than companies do so if
you first it's if you're an individual
running a business because an individual
getting a salary if you're reporting a
negative income I'd be very pissed off
at your employer and what now but if
it's a business you're allowed to carry
forward losses as well right and there
your tax savings will be at the
individual tax rate unless you decide to
perform a sub chapter S or some other
kind of incorporation but the same rules
apply
right let talk about capex right
remember what I said about capex it's
best to Twin it with depreciation
because one gives right to the other the
reason I always TW twin and reported as
net cap X because in most statements you
say plus depreciation and then three
line items below minus capex my worry
when you separate the two is people
sometimes forget that they're connected
and they put different growth rates in
the two and before you know it the two
line items take a life of their own and
that's how you end up with with cash
flow discarded cash flow valuation the
depreciation is 30% higher than the
capex and keeps growing
what are you depreciating it's gone so
connect the two the net capex should
reflect what kind of growth you see for
your company said or talked about story
you're giving a high growth story I
would expect to see high net capex at
least from a financial definition of net
capx your assumptions about net Capa
have to be linked to your assumptions
about growth in revenues and operating
income not to historical capex growth
and historical depreciation growth
right so that said though and we've
already laid the foundation our
definition of net capex is much broader
than the accounting definition of net
capex capex minus depreciation and
statement of cash flows the accounting
definition is very much locked into
fixed assets long-term physical Assets
Now my definition of net capex includes
R&D capitalization but it also includes
another huge capex that accountant
somehow give a free pasture you're a
company you want to grow and you're in a
hurry to grow takes a long time to grow
with internal Investments right so what
do you do you go out and do an
acquisition an acquisition is just a
gigantic capex it's an external capex as
opposed to internal capex so in my
definition of net
capex
Acquisitions are part of capex and it
doesn't matter whether you pay with
stock or cash and I'm going to lay the
foundation for this don't let companies
evade cash flows by arguing that they
use stock to pay for things this is
going to come back again you know when
when we talk about stock based
compensation this is
non-cash the analogy I will give is
really simplistic but take it for what
it's worth let's say you run a pizzeria
you have six people working for you you
pay the minimum wages that's all you can
afford to pay they're not happy they're
hungry the end of every day you give
them each three
pizzas it's non cash right but is it I
mean 3 * 6 is 18 pizzas you charge $20 a
pizza that's 18 * 20
$360 in effect you've given up that's
what I mean about in kind as opposed to
non-cash depreciation is a non-cash
expense but paying for something with
stock is not a non-cash expense it's an
in kind use equity to pay
for and valueing companies which grow
through Acquisitions is much more
difficult than valuing companies that
grow with Organic Investments why
because Acquisitions are lumpy so when
you look at a company's history you
might do a lot of Acquisitions one year
not very so you almost have to look
across time to see what they've done
it's a way of the world it's not a good
thing or a bad thing it's a reality of F
and in some cases if the acquisition is
non-cash you'll have to start digging
through footnotes because if it's
non-cash it WS to open your statement of
cash flows right so you also enough to
say what did they pay for it in terms of
shares issued or you know whatever the
the compensation was so net cap X is a
very different number in finance than
you get in an accounting statement so
I'll give you an example of how wide the
difference can be one of the great
companies the 1990s was Cisco yesterday
when I was in CNBC and they were talk
were talking about Nvidia I remember
being on I don't know what there was no
CNBC I guess in the 1990s but the
equivalent you know what was there CNBC
maybe there was no the during the com Bo
Cisco was a
superstar for a brief period in 1999
Cisco was the most valuable company in
the world for like 15 minutes $400
billion company it went from 4 billion
to 400 billion in one decade Harvard
Business School wrote case studies
because Cisco was a very unique company
the way it grew was through
Acquisitions they would buy small
technology companies that SWAT team that
would come in and convert into
commercial prodct they were very good at
and this is the peak of Cisco's Glory
1999 this is how much they spent in that
one year on Acquisitions you'll notice
that it says method of acquisition
purchase versus pooling before the the
accounting rules change there were two
ways you could account for an
acquisition if you paid with cash it's
called purchase acquisition in which
case you showed Goodwill looks very much
like we do now but if you paid with
shares you were allowed to in a sense
bypass balance sheets you didn't have to
show Goodwill you didn't have to show
what you originally paid and a lot of
companies took advantage of it take a
look at Cisco they had three big three
pooling transactions and six but the big
Acquisitions they made all were pooling
because they paid with chairs in some
Cisco paid $2.5 billion spent five $2.5
billion in Acquisitions I'm going to
treat it as part of my capex this looks
very unfair right it's going to make
their cash flows negative
but when I look at the free cash flows
when I look at the net capex for Cisco
if I just stayed with the accounting
number it looks like they're reinvesting
only 98 million so that's the accounting
cap X accounting depreciation but I
bring in R&D I bring in
Acquisitions they investing 3.7 billion
so what's the bad news when I compute
the free cash flow to the firm for Cisco
there's going to be a huge reinvestment
and a negative free cash flow what's a
good news when I forecast our future
growth for Cisco I'm going to look at
what they're reinvesting and say look I
can give them a 30% growth rate not
because I'm feeling generous but because
they're reinvesting you know the net
effect for Cisco was a positive number
in
1999 but the reason you have to bring
Acquisitions into your capex is if you
do not do that and you give the company
the benefit of growth that comes from
Acquisitions then you're having a free
lunch right you're counting the growth
now come when analyst routinely used to
over value G between 1985 and 1990 by
doing this they look at past earnings
growth projected out but G did a lot of
Acquisitions often with shares they
wouldn't count that as part of the capex
so geez grown with almost nothing
reinvested it's happening you're just
missing it so we bring in Acquisitions
not because we want to punish companies
but because we want to make sure we
capture what's being
us working capital again I'm going to
kind of shake your accounting Basics
loose and kind of give you a different
definition we know the accounting
definition is Right current assets minus
current
liabilities it's not the
definition we use in in valuation the
difference between non-cash current
assets and non-debt current liabilities
let me take the half that's easier to
work with when you look at the current
liabilities for a company what are some
of the items you're going to see under
current
lities P accounts payable supplier
credit
keep going though what else are you
going to see shortterm debt shortterm
portion of long-term debt that shows up
there right here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to take short-term debt
short-term portion of long-term debt
take it out of current liabilities throw
it in with debt in my cost of capital
and give it a long-term cost of
debt so that's why I take de out of
that's easy half let's start to the
current asset side you've got inventory
you got receivables you got other
current assets and then you got
cash and it's a gigantic number for
companies like Google and apple right
billion and here I think we need to step
back and think about what it is about
inventory or receive if any of you had a
family business that was a retail
business your Dad or Mom or whoever R
the business went into the store room
and saw it filled to the top with
inventory he or she would have cringed
saying this is terrible is L what's so
wrong about having a lot of inventory
it's great for customers walking in
because you have every shoe size and
every shoe
style but the problem is while it's
sitting on the shelves it's a wasting
asset that's why inventory affects your
cash flows because it is doesn't get
converted to cash till it get
sold inventories are wasting assets when
you sell stuff on credit and you don't
charge
interest it's a wasting asset the
question about cash is is cash a wasting
asset or more put differently what has
to be true for cash to be a wasting
asset I'm sorry
what under the mat we're getting closer
right because let's take apple 180
billion in cash where's that cash
usually in it's not under somebody's
mattress because then Tim Cook would be
sleeping on a mattress that was really
really really high
it's usually invest in commercial paper
and Tes because in the US you you're
supposed to keep it liquid and riskless
so bonds are too risky because the price
can change it's commercial pay and what
are they earning right now you think on
that but 4.4 4.3 5% say that's a really
low number let me ask you a question any
of you have a brokerage account that's
usually a cash amount in the brokerage
account sitting as cash you're letting
your brokerage account rip you off right
and you deserve
it you know that if you have enough cash
you can buy treasuries yourself you can
there's a treasury auction you can want
I think you need a minimum 50,000 in
cash or something I can buy treasuries
now I can in fact I did this yesterday I
going of roll my cash over into
six-month treasuries I was getting
4.34% so what's Apple is making looks
low until you say that's what I would
make on something liquid and riskless
you see what I'm going cash for the most
spot today is invested to earn a fair
rate of return given that's riskless and
liquid it's not a wasting asset so what
has to be true for cash to be a wasting
asset as Gabrielle pointed out it's got
to be under your mattress what kind of
business would run with cash under the
mattress maybe you're a drug
cartel and you want me to attach a value
to you it's breaking bad right basically
you know I've got a lot of cash on the
back room here come on in first you
shouldn't take that valuation assignment
it's not a good idea cuz the consequence
of getting the value wrong might be
catastrophic for you but if you decide
to take that assignment and count cash
is part of working capital the reason I
bring that up is that are these rules of
term that I see floating around
valuation that know some were created by
McKenzie some by others that companies
need operating cash of 2% of revenues
and they be put into working
capital do companies sometimes need
operating cash no you
retail you know Walmart probably needs
cash in the tills right because there's
still people who pay with cash that need
change less than it used
to but if you hang around to Walmart all
day not a great idea but if you hang
around you might they might call the
police on you but hang around somewhere
hide behind something you'll notice that
they clear out the cash on a regular
basis and roll it into a money-making
account so it's operating cash but it's
not wasting cash so the question I have
is not do you need cash for operations
but is it wasting cash the answer is no
it shouldn't be part of working
capital so when we're looking at
non-cash working capital that's
basically what we're looking at is the
portion of working capital that's not
wasting net of the current liabilities
that are not interest pairing and that's
the amount that shows up in your cash
flows as a general proposition though I
have never and I mentioned this right at
the start of the class I've never ever
broken working capital down into its
individual components
inventory receivables payables because
it's not worth it this is one of those
numbers numbers will jump around numbers
jump around you have a better shot
consolidating working capital and
forecasting it into the future usually
as a percentage of revenues tied to
something that is an operating
number will it be volatile yeah it'll be
all over the place but when you're
forecasting you make it a per of
revenues that volatility is getting
smoothed
out one final point on working capital
can your non-c working capital be
negative yeah right so your accounts
payable and Supply CR what are you doing
when you you know Amazon for the first s
years maybe 10 years of its existence
had negative working
capital what do that do to your cash
flows first you have negative working
capital it increases your cash flows
because as you grow you say what the
heck is going on this is almost magical
for the first decade the Amazon business
model was they bought stuff from let's
say originally online book retailer they
bought stuff from Publishers and because
Publishers wanted an online conduit for
their books they often gave Amazon 60 90
days to pay then Amazon would sell books
to you and I and they definitely didn't
give you 60 or 90 days to pay you paid
right away they had a float they were
using supplier Credit in a way to grow
and sounds like an amazing source of
credit right because what does it not
not have that a bank loan has it doesn't
have an
explicit interest payment notice what I
said no explicit interest
payment is there an implicit interest
payment when you supply a credit what do
suppliers usually when they let you say
you can have 60 days these are not
mother teresas on the other side so when
they say you can have 60 days it comes
with a little cats right if you pay
right away you get a cash
discount the thing we're often missing
when we treat supplier credit as free
because people would look at the Amazon
model say why doesn't everybody do
this one your credit risk is going to go
through the roof you have huge amounts
of supplyer credit the second it's not
free it's a way of raising capital and
when you're small it might be a good way
to raise Capital because it's growing
with your operations tied to what you do
but eventually as you scale up it's
going to get at least smaller you can't
have minus 20% of revenues of working
capital in perity so if you have a
company negative working capital don't
freak out there are businesses out there
that it can be a source of cash but it
is what it is
yes excuse me are you implicitly saying
that at that point that there is no risk
of default for the company that's that's
the other thing that's why I said
supplier credit has risk you don't see
it until you hit a crutch right in is
risky as well it's making you a more
risky company but because it's not
explicit you don't notice your rating
dropping your interest rate going up so
it's a very Insidious way you get into
trouble many young businesses you supply
a credit you supply a credit they're
growing nobody notices but then your
growth levels off and all of a sudden
your supplier credit starts to become
this existential threat to you so I
think we underestimate how much cost and
risk there is to supply a credit and
that's a good reason why many companies
limit their use of it even though it
looks like an easy and a cheap way to
raise
Capital let's talk about free cash load
Equity the simplest measure is look at
what companies pay there dividends and
increasingly in the US they're returning
cash in the form of
BuyBacks but the problem is that what
companies return is not always what they
can return actual cash return is not
equal to PO itial cash return so let's
start there and this requires a
revisiting of corporate finance why do
some companies choose not to return what
they can afford to what are some of the
reasons PA what might a company which
has 100 million in cash available to
return choose not to
return want to use it for operating it's
after capex after operating expense so
this is 100 million after you met every
expense so there's no no need for it
anymore more it's like cash in the T why
might you still choose not to return
they want to
have no cash one is they might think
about future Investments they said right
now we have excess cash so one reason
you hold back cash is your investment
needs might shift over time
yes but this is after remember you know
if it's really potential dividence after
capex after working capital after R&D
so's saying there are thing things they
still they did why didn't they already
do it right so one could be that they
want to wait and do it next year one is
they haven't thought of what to do but
they will think of something to do
that's terrifying right because now they
have your cash and what are they doing
they're going around looking say where
can I spend it and there there's an
ecosystem of people saying I can help
you spend
it so that's a terrifying thought I want
to do an acquisition it could also be
because once a cash leaves the company
you no longer control it right what
greed greed only in the sense that you
can steal from the company we're taking
that off the table right so maybe
they're taking the money and building
you know chat on the top of mountains
and living in them but the bottom line
is companies don't pay out what they can
afford to B so they're conservative or
they hold on to cash and that creates
this disconnect the oldest discounted
cash flow model around is a dividend
discount model if it's built on the
presumption that companies pay out what
they can afford to but if they don't a
dividend discount model will misestimate
the value of a company so I want to talk
about potential dividends how can you
figure out what a company can afford to
pay out yes is it also the fact that if
they pay out cash then their stock price
is reduced by that amount let not let's
not go there because that's kind of
irrelevant right so if I if your stock
is at 20 and I pay you a dollar in
dividend the dollar goes into your
pocket the stock is worth $9 are you at
worth
of as an outside investor no but like a
lot of the compe as any investor your
total return includes what dividends and
price appreciation so as long as the
price drop is roughly the dividend I'm
no worse off than receiving in fact that
dollar can now go to Nidia stock instead
of going back in this company right so
you could actually argue that you'd
rather have the cash in your pocket if
you got a boring company that's going up
6% % a year so I don't think that's an
issue right that might drive your
dividends versus BuyBacks if you want to
keep the price up because you have
options or other stuff but that
shouldn't be the reason for not paying
them yes seen from the markets like the
company kind of like
spoil the signaling effect you know what
I can take whatever signaling story you
tell me and give you the opposite story
so is it is paying dividends a good
signal or a bad
signal I could no no wait wait can can
paying dividends somebody take the other
side can paying dividends be a bad
signal yeah if Nvidia pays a big
dividend oh my God I thought the AI was
going to be a huge Market what the heck
is going on I have very little faith in
signaling stories for that reason
because you can see already depending on
the company and you know depending on
what you thought you were sending as a
signal it could be a very different
signal but whatever it is dividends and
potential Dividends are different be
nice to know what those potential
Dividends are I'll tell you what you
cannot use as potential dividend I've
seen analysts discount
earnings as if they were cash flows the
argument is a company can pay its entire
earnings out as dividend first are
companies allowed to do that no you can
pay your earnings out as dividends well
there's an earnings is not cash flow
thing but if you get over that but if
you do pay your earnings out as
dividends and you choose to do that what
kind of growth rate should I give you as
a company zero right so if you want to
treat earnings as cash flows be my guess
but I don't want to see a 3% growth rate
in that number every year right so I
don't think earnings work as cash flows
because you got this growth issue coming
up so the potential dividends for a
company should First Take earnings and
convert them to cash flows add back the
non-cash charges and then subtract out
the reinvestment you need for growth
and if you're looking at Equity cash
flows I also have to subtract our debt
payments due and other stuff due with
that I'm leading you to what I'm going
to call Free Cash Road Equity but you
can see the intuition that I want to the
way I think about free cash Road Equity
is I'm a business owner this is the cash
left in the till at the end of the year
after I've met every conceivable
need so let's say now I'm going to use
the analogy of a checkbook even though
most of you my daughter doesn't even
know what a check looks like she had to
write a certified check she said dad I
don't have any checkbooks and you know
so we had to walk into a bank open an
account start a check she thought was
the most torturous thing ever but let's
let's use the analogy of a checkbook
right you're a business owner you made
money you're starting to write checks
out check to cack check to working
capital check to Deb what's left in the
account after you've written all those
checks and they've been cashed is cash
you can take out of the
business so that's why don't get caught
up in the free cash flow Equity sounds
fancy but basically it's cash left after
every need has been met so to compute
free cash or Equity I'm going to start
with net income why because it's an
equity cash flow I'm looking at earnings
to equity investors I'm going to
subtract at net capex which you if you
want to is adding back depreciation
subtracting capex I'm going to subtract
out changes in non-cash working capital
and I'm also going to net out the effect
of debt cuz debt can create both cash
outflows from repayment and cash inflows
if I take new debt the N amount what I'm
left with at the bottom line is the free
cash flow
Equity it's free because it's after
every conable it's a cash flow because
in effect I've added back depreciation
amortization it's to equity because it's
after debt
payments if I hadn't subtracted out the
debt payments i' have free cash flow to
the firm so essentially always one step
divide this is the potential dividend
this can be paid out without affecting
any of the operations of the company
because it's after
reinvestment it is your potential div so
take a look at the items you see there
and tell me which financial statement
you're most likely to be able to get net
income capex depreciation changes in
working capital new debt issues debt
repay which financial statement am I
most likely to be able to get
them it's going to be in the statement
of cash flows
statement of cash flow starts with net
income right and in the operating
section you're going to get depreciation
and amortization and change in working
capital it's all in that first section
you go below that you got the investing
section you're going to get dep capex
Acquisitions in there and then you go
below that you got the financing section
it's all
there and in fact one of the advantages
of working with the statement of cash
flows is the cash flow sign already
tells you what to do so you don't have
to subtract capex the statement of cash
flows why because the cash flow comes
with a minus in front of it so for God's
sakes don't minus the minus and make
your capex into a positive number right
so when you're doing statement of cash
flows all of the cash flows have their
signs preserved now do you see why
estimating potential dividends is
Trivial it's the easiest exercise in
valuation it's all in one statement you
never need to leave it and you
essentially end up with a free cash flow
de
so now I want to tie this back to this
notion of a corporate life cycle because
when you compute this for your company
you're got to get a number you say why
is my number what it is let's get some
perspective let's think about a company
moving through the life cycle we kind of
laid the foundation for it because I
started the class with that question is
Jessica you know you a young company
what is this cash flow going to look
like your net income is negative your
lot of reinvestment you NE no your free
cash Equity is going to be negative if
you move through the life cycle and
you're a healthy company and you scale
up at some point in time your net income
will start to turn positive right but
odds are you're still with negative free
cash load Equity because even though
you've started to make money you're
still reinvesting a lot net income will
usually turn the corner before free cash
L Equity work because free cash Equity
is after reinvest and then you growth
starts to level off and you're pissed
off right you don't want growth to level
off but there's good news that comes
from growth leveling off which is when
you have less growth what do you need to
do less
of reinvest less that's the bonus you
reinvest less your free cash so your
free cash flow Equity will turn positive
when you're turning less optimistic
about your growth rates and then you
become a mature company you are at the
peak of your cash flow generating
capacity you're making a lot of money
you're very little in
reinvestment you can do BuyBacks you can
pay out dividends then you go into
decline everything starts to go down
with it so if you think about where
you're in the life cycle you can see the
free cash flow play out over the life
cycle so I've been tracking Tesla for a
long time first time I valued Tesla in
2013 huge negative free cash
recording money losing company lots of
reinvestment in fact there's where the
net the net income is the green number
from 2006 the year of its founding to
2019 Tesla never ever made money you
start with a negative number reinvest a
lot you saying why is the free cash
order Equity jumping because year they
buildt a factory it's a big free cash
negative free cash order years so
basically the the swings in the free
cash reflect the lumpiness of their
investments in 2020 for the first
time Tesla reported profits but it free
cash Equity is actually close to zero
why because they were still reinvesting
enough that their profits were
2021 you made profits in first time in
Tesla's history that POS POS free cash
load Equity it's kind of a mixed
blessing right the positive free cash
load Equity is good news the company's
finally made it what's the bad news
there if you're putting 50% growth and
Tesla still the question I'm asking you
is you know where is that reinvestment
that will drive that growth rate so it's
it's it's both good and bad news but
it's sometimes good to track a company
through the cycle to see its free cash
flow equity evolv
I haven't done the 2024 version I'm
working on it I'm a long flight to
Portugal tonight I will finish it up on
dividends and free cast Equity across
all publicly traded companies and and I
it's very simple what I do is I take all
publicly traded companies I take the
dividends and the stock BuyBacks both of
which are in the statement of cash flows
and then I compute the free cash FL
equity for every company and if you look
at this table you can see this is the
2023 version there's my free cash load
Equity collectively global companies at
1.63 trillion in free cash
recording collectively in
2023 global companies return 3.9
billion and the US is in fact one of the
bigger culprits in terms of that
mismatch between free cash Acy more cash
is being returned than is available to
be
returned how are they making up the
difference you know for the moment it
could be you know at some point in time
you could bring in new leverage to make
up the difference new stock issuances
that you're not capturing here and the
in the US what's G what's Bridging the
Gap is you have new companies going
public new stock being issued making up
the Prof the mature companies in the US
are paying out they basically in a sense
shrinking themselves
right and I think that's healthy because
you're making room for the new people to
come in if you look at know markets like
Europe you see a much closer match
because because mature companies kind of
hang around they're know they they kind
of want to keep going they've got too
many sustainability experts around
telling them you got to live you got to
live forever you know you know this is
the way you live forever and the
consequence is there's no room for young
companies going to make it into the the
game so that calculation of free cash
Equity is a little messy all those
different items there's a shortcut you
can use if you're willing to make an
assumption the assumption is that a
fixed percentage of your reinvestment
always comes from De what kinds of
companies could you do in a mature
company say 25% of a reinvestment always
comes from debt and here's the shortcut
you start with net income like I did
before you take the net capex but you
look at only the equity portion the 75%
that comes from Equity remember you're
completely focused on yourself as an
equity investor you take the change in
working capital you look at the 75% that
comes from you and you end up with free
cash Equity you're saying where's the
debt issuance and debt repayments they
go away because they're in that
25% it works only if you have a company
with a stable debt ratio you can make
that prediction so I'm going to close
today with a very simple example so
example I use my applied corporate
finance class I look at Disney and
Disney it's a long time ago in 1997 had
free cash load Equity of 704 million 97
took the net income subtract net capex
time 1us the debt ratio the debt ratio
is about 24% 76% comes from Equity 24%
from debt with a 24% debt ratio the free
cash Equity was 74 million they paid our
345 million in dividends now you can see
if I use a dividend discount model to
Value Disney I will undervalue
Equity but I'm going to play a little
game here that's going to lead to a
puzzling conclusion see that 24% that
comes from debt what would happen to my
free cash Lo Equity if I made that 24%
into 40% if I got more my
reinvestment from debt what's going to
happen to my free cash FL Equity will it
increase or
decrease it's going to increase because
I have to come up with less right if I
make it 50% even free cash Equity will
go up even more so here's the magic the
more debt I use the better I look like
on a free cash or Equity basis and if
the value of equity is free cash or
Equity discounted by the cost of equity
this leads to a very disquieting
conclusion which is I should be at 99%
debt
there's something I must be missing
right cost of equity which is what I use
comes from using a beta remember we
don't use regression betas if I use
regression beta I'm going to get trapped
but if I remember we talked about
Levering betas if I compute that lever
beta as my debt ratio goes up my cost of
equity is also going to go
up the cash flows go up cost of equity
goes up which one do you think will
dominate I'll give you the choices Maybe
increasing Leverage is always good for
Value because the cash flow effect will
dominate the discount rate
effect if that were the case what should
companies all do be almost entirely debt
finan maybe the discount rate effect
will always dominate the cash flow
effect in which case what should
companies do never use
that maybe this magical thing can happen
which is the cash flow effect and the
discount rate effect will exactly offset
each other say how does that matter
magic happen this one of corporate
finance's most famous
theorems which one am I talking about
let's see if you remember your Corporate
Finance it's called the melani theorem
in a world with no taxes and no default
risk the effects will exactly
offset of course you have to live in a
world with no taxes and no default risk
in the real world that's not the world
we live in especially as April 15 gets
closer and closer in the real world any
of those three things can be true for a
segment so for the next debt ratio maybe
your cost value of equity will go up but
if you keep doing it for the same firm
it and that's see the rationale behind
there being a right mix of debt and
Equity so when we did Corporate Finance
we did this through the cost to Capital
being minimized think of this as a
different vehicle to arrive at the same
conclusion looking at free cash FL
equity and cost of equity so we'll stop
there when we start again reminder we'll
start with the first 30 minutes of quiz
and then afterward we're going to talk
about growth more growth and still more
growth so we're done with cash flows the
quiz will cover all the way through this
page 160 so